with all the fear and the uncertainty
both of cobit and its economic
impact many people who were thinking of
having a baby are now putting those
plans on hold
and those who don't want to get pregnant
are taking extra cautions
so nurex which is the largest digital
practice for women's health saw
a 50 increase in requests for birth
control prescriptions
when the pandemic hit in march and also
a 40
increase in demand for the morning after
pill
everything from financial security or
insecurity
truthfully um as well as
you know fears around having to go into
the hospital and giving birth during
this time so
you know it's it's a whole host of
reasons that we believe are underlying
this increase in demand for
contraception
now there are lots of studies that prove
a direct link between an economic
downturn
and birth rates going all the way back
to the great recession a decade ago
states where the recession
was the most severe experienced largest
drops in births
now researchers at the brookings
institution have forecast there could be
a half million
fewer babies born in america this year
interesting